former almost Bachelorette Brittany
Wilson is engaged hearing to post last
night
[Music]
the 30 year old reality star took to
social media to share the exciting news
boyfriend Jeremy Brinn popped the
question after a year and eight months
of dating
Brett posted several pics of the pair
and this video detailing how her man got
down on one knee I no idea I welcome to
kitchen everything's normal and then I
walked around and I saw um
white rose petals all over the ground
and kind of a little pathway of candles
and then got down on my knee which is a
crazy thing any guys who are watching us
who have gotten married like asking the
woman you love to marry you it feels
like it just is it's the most natural
thing because it's bull devolved one but
it actually requires the question being
asked when you spend the rest of your
life with me and marry me and she said
I'll get back to you oh my god no no she
brett exclusively tells ET she knew
jeremy was the one quote before we even
met i prayed about it and I just knew in
2015 Brit and Kaitlyn Bristowe went head
to head as the first ever dueled
bachelorettes after the two were
eliminated from crystals season of The
Bachelor the whole thing was just the
most awkward situation ever the suitors
chose Caitlin over Britt as the official
Bachelorette but a it worked out for
both ladies Caitlin is still engaged to
her winner Shawn booth and brent has
found her prince charming in 34 year-old
hairstylist Jeremy she also revealed to
eat see they are planning on getting
hitched right away quote we are thinking
late August early September as soon as
we can
[Music]
you